Like a just. So yes. Whoever's i have to
say i have to say that again. All right.
Well so we had a an old man a mr.
smith who was about to retire
and he decided he'd buy the smallest
post-office he could find and retire.
So of course he bought the neiman post-office
and ended up up here in the heyday.
When the town was starting to boom
and he would get the most ridiculous
letters addressed to people like rainbow
and the treehouse tangible
falls and he by the end of it.
He was quite spare he could do high blood
pressure he was really quite that easy.
And yet one morning i remember
walking into the post office
and he was throwing a tantrum
and he had hauled someone across
the counter by their shirt collar
and was you know screaming abuse at them
and he had another man at work for him.
Named nole who was no he was
so mild mannered and then
when just chucked the wobblies and
knowledge kind of look stone faced
that you're not i said to
know how you deal with it.
You know i couldn't stand and he said
i'll wait until it's no it around.
I go out onto the back step
and i piss myself laughing
and you know you know you died a
couple years ago it was very sad.
He was there you know
going to the post office
and make love with no you cross
the cancer with darling.
He's not do them but who is really going
through this food but mr smith retired
and sold it to another for poor unfortunate
man who now gets abused i think in many
other day when been abused by some
very out of it looking character.
You know
and just to think what the wild
west can be at times can't
can be very and it seems to be cyclic to
you know devices it's just gorgeous and.
Couldn't have ever imagined
live anywhere else
and other days you think i have to seriously
consider the direction of my life
where i come from the money.
So you and your friends
go overseas interests
and i think i'm so bored.
So that you know but. I
consider it like people.
Oh yes.
When we first started the rainbow cafe it
wasn't as it appears to this day it had
little rooms that was still you know
had their partitions and things
and every saturday we would have to vacate
one of these little rooms at the back
and this can come in.
Plugged his phone in and
the way he'd go and
when we realized what he was drinkers
used to try and keep us locked down
but we would just tease him.
Open the door and pretend to
put on be so to the police
but there are no fears
me i won't get changed
and things like this because we saw so have
to back at bath out on another part of
the back verandah there because by using
facilities were fairly scarce it was very
good for local baker he was the local
baker who became very very wealthy from
having it up a lot of the land around here
and he knew after he was a
bakery sell the baker bakery
and they became a real estate agent
and cleaned up and then moved.
Thank you very much it killing.
Oh yeah yeah well we don't you
know we don't know we don't know
that really i think is making it
any time for the bakery or he
owned by people and we live here
and so during the best of all
the people from the feed.
Well family gave him a recipe for.
Loaf which became the aquarius
known and he baked that
and sold it all around the area and
each time the bakery had been sold
that recipe is part of the deal.
I think they change it
every time a changed hands
that doesn't really resemble
anything like what i used to know.
But it was all made with organic grain
and it was very tasty.
Rolls with.
Job. You know the difficult life.
Yeah was pretty primitive language and
yes very primitive as lugging water
and.
Hosing down nappies learned then doing the
best you could do as far as shelter guys.
Yeah i lived in a cow bales that had.
No wall on one side the front of it
was just a garden and we had a hose
and a baby's back a big
cuss don't have. Outside.
No water in the actual
house and the woodstove
that was totally unenclosed so at night
time in the winter was very cold and
that was where my second child was born
and we lived there for another couple of
years before we moved to another community
and i was not impressed as a banshee i
think barely have to scription chuck
wobblies regularly hurl
the plates to them.
I didn't believe like this is not
what i was cut out for at all.
How do children it wasn't as difficult
for me and i quite enjoyed that.
I mean it was like just continuing the
playhouse best specter of my childhood
and and being in north queensland
too are very different climate and.
We still make these amazing
to call them plastic palaces.
With a staple gun builders
plastic in the month.
Trees along water's edge queensland.
So it was different but when
we were here during. Festival.
It was often very cold and the only
place you could bathe was in the creek
and hence the bucket bands at the back
of the rainbow and things like that.
Well tropical authors were a problem.
A lot of people used to get really really
bad for the good old and basically
that was because hygiene was
difficult and change of diet
and change of lifestyle tends to bring
more of those things there and also
that aspell and when it's seeds.
I don't know why
but you have to stick sister i think
you definitely get stuck to your skin
and often if there was a little cut
or grace there you'd end up with a
tropical ulcer and you would see
and i think partly it was
diet as well. People may be.
Going from being meted purely vegetarian
and not getting the right
protein balance and you know
and often not enough food
too little and good food.
We didn't.
Why one of my dear friends was pregnant at
the time and. We still sweet on her she.
I think it was six weeks before the birth
just to get $25 a fortnight and so.
And i was a smoker and
quite a heavy smoker
and she used to buy me a
packet of drama out of
that money every week every fortnight
if she could it wasn't every fortnight
actually and we would
go to lismore to the u.
P r u a the u.
P a room which was like country
women's association food
and we'd have corned beef and you know
with white sauce and boiled vegan
and pudding and.
If you have a real feel of raisin and
dissidents how will you know with a cloth
and i always ask you did you know i
think that's a big treat. Yeah yeah.
The single women around here that
was pensions were very popular
and they would be a whole household centred
around this woman on a single pension.
Yeah i feel we tell stories of that.
Now that thunderball right you
know they did use them because
that you couldn't get social security
but there was no you know the
single mothers would get it.
Is.
Broad was the only vd on
one queensland story.
I think it was the force
community that i lived on.
Living on a community well there's so
many different ways that it can be done.
Roberts i would say one of the more
successful ones because the land was already
owned by someone there was no necessity to
just take any comer to who had money to
buy a share.
So we managed to establish a very slowly
with extended family often brothers
and sisters brothers and brothers mothers
and brothers children so incense
and friends. Yeah you had to sort of you
have to be in really and it works because.
We all
but real strong heart communication between
the reporting it is rather like a big
extended family you know which means.
The non entrepreneurial
and the entrepreneurial.
I mean places like which
is people that live it.
Town of along my imagine
has its ups and downs.
Because you don't get to
choose your neighbors
but once again tangible very established
and a lot of those people have known each
other for a really really long time.
So there's a very strong
contingent of old friends.
That i would say counterbalances.
The adverse things that happen
when you don't have any choice
about who you live with
and i don't think westerns
are very good at that
and i think we're very basic i think
we're commune all animals we're very
territorial
and so i don't really really feel though i
think feel economically communities work
i don't think in the real sense.
People tend to isolate themselves and.
A portion of this is mine and you know if
you stop on my vegie patch of. Bangla.
Those skills. Yeah but it's no natural
one for we know my son and i know
that sort of training really if you think.
And going you know your
occasionally is really good
and communicate it come home
anything come but you switch
and indians do it so much better yet.
So much better human amount living
in close proximity with one another.
Condition very much.
Because a lot of the communities these days
are run in the sense of an equal share
like i mean people even these
days have their own title
and they have a portion of land that
is theirs that they can defend you
and if they want to do so really they're
not all communities some of them are
glorified subdivisions
though they're low cost.
Rural accommodation for people
so in one sense they're vital.
I mean i don't put them down at all though
i wouldn't choose to live like that.
So for the foreseeable.
It's come full circle out of
people's needs to be able to resell.
You know can honestly come full circle
because it is difficult on our community we
cannot sell our share and
we don't own a house
and you know you know constitution.
It's the company that owns everything.
And so we have that's us
too. So you know i mean.
So we have to be sure
that our relationships are very
good if you want to go somewhere.
You don't go believing in a screaming
heap you actually leave fairly a legally
and you have other things
that you have to do so.
You do community organizers who
they want to live in your house and
that person reimburses you but your
shares are totally non-refundable
and that's the deal where
all of us agree to
that because their shares are
incredibly reasonably priced
and there's only a small number
of them. Trust her. Much indeed.
Yeah yeah
but we built on trust because we didn't
have any tenure at all in the beginning
when we built there and the woman
that owned the land as one very
extraordinary human being.
So we trusted her and she trusted
us and it's worked really well.
But that's just like you
really do you feel like
that.
You. Do your my god.
Mind got him you know. About
this one chasing other.
We don't really need to discuss
the drug problem. Everybody else.
You know about animals and we and that
and it's sad changes the town is like
we've noticed in the last two years
particularly that things are
going on here that is expanding.
I mean to the point where we don't
have parking anymore in the street.
It's a battle to even you know been.
There's lots of new
businesses that have opened
and they seem to be sustaining themselves.
What. Well.
We are accused of having become
more straight. I think and.
Whatever that means i think
that there are many more people
who were original accrues people
that have decided to make a livelihood.
But most of those people
that i know make it out of something
they really enjoy doing so i don't know
that i can see that as i said and also i
think their value system they've kept it.
Yeah way back there.
We did 10 throw a few
babies that we had to go
and sort of start to shortly bring them
back and say sorry you were right.
Mum and dad society sorry
we were a bit hazy
but in the long term. No we did throw.
A lot of bathwater and it was
really good to get rid of.
But we do have to survive you know we do
have to leave and we have to face that
and you know. Look at society you think.
Yes okay we'll try and feed him
and as much on our terms
as possible for you know.
Mom was a bit possibly the aquarian idea
so the beginning of the green movement.
I think we need talked about the
necessity i don't really think yet for a
revolution i truly believe that the
ecological movement is the revolution.
I mean there was no way the society
was just going to collapse.
But the an extraordinary amount of
waste that we produce as a race.
If we didn't have the green movement
where the heck would we be.
I mean they're like the watch it on even
though they taken 20 years for it to get
gain any momentum at all for any training
and years ago we were sitting down crying
about it then and and totally impotent
and didn't know what
to do but could see it
and people were talking about
it in real terms back then.
If you had the years to hear it and nothing
was done and 20 years down the track.
I mean that's why i sometimes catch
myself thinking it's too late and praying
that it is and.
I think it's really difficult but it
does seem to have a bit of a hold. Now.
And it's moving ahead.
And people are becoming conscious
of it and we've done it again.
We've done
that in the real funny way i've got a
friend who dresses up as an old lady
and goes to supermarkets with born
to shop bags and badges you know.
And she just advises everyone in the
supermarket what's best things via has a great
time doing it goes off to all
the markets and i'm celeste.
Less feel shop best but i think also
that forest protesters protests that we
had around him an area where they were
that all markets and for a lot of.
A subsequent movements
and at the time there was the biggest uproar
about the hippies telling the loggers
what to do. I mean we
worked the confrontations
that some of those the terrain in one
in particular i remember was horrible.
I mean you know people being
hauled off trees and it was not
that really broke new
ground and really dead
and it has made a very big it's made people
more courageous about speaking up for
what they believe in and chaining
themselves to trees if they feel
that that's necessary. So i do believe that
the aquarius movement yes there chris.
Estival but that whole period in time.
Was the beginning of
that of any real change as far as they go.
But if you go to. You know i'm a little
bit. I think a result of a funny one.
Okay i'll tell you about being in
jail like being in jail part of
it but it was it was fun.
I shouldn't say you know.
We had this old car.
Carter going to have to tell all these
awful things we have this old car an old
holden called louis good
australian name that jim
and i had bought from a friend of ours
called robbie in sydney was supposed to pay
my hundred dollars. We paid him 20.
Neither of us had a licence and
we left sydney at about 2 a.m.
So we wouldn't have any traffic both time
we got to hornsby is it already lost
second gear. So we went up
and we arrived at my parents place on
route to him and were coming to him
and to work the festival and.
Evaded all the questions about the
legalities of this piece that we had
and then we came up here.
And we were at the story is about driving
down to the beach down past byron bay
with a call for a broken.
Had when we went down there was a caravan
park there anyway so we parked louis.
G there and we went down to the
beach and the tide came in.
So we were able to swim around a couple
of beaches away from the caravan park
and as we come out of north queensland
we've been running naked for a couple of
years already. Off went the clothes
and then we went for a good swim.
And i must tell you.
Jill was nearly nine months pregnant with
tinking at this point in time so she was
very big and round and round things you
know breasts is renowned for its teeth
and to blue eyes in case this guy
goes to defocus for that pub.
Beautiful blue but i feel it anyway.
So we'd have a swim in july and
i was sitting on the beach
and we could see a guy i
don't know he was stupid.
I mean something to remember or fishing
and and he waved as he went past
and he climbed up was like
go trail over the mountain
and back around the caravan park
and there was nobody you know
and until we looked up and
here are two policemen.
Well two men police and
coming down over the hill.
So we sort of had a little discussion
about what to do so i will just stay put.
It's okay you know i mean surely they could
handle we're sitting down you know it's
not much to see and and jules
we've seen how you swim and.
These men walk right up to us
and we sort of that's really insensitive
you know now what. And they said.
Where police get your
clothes on girlie you know.
And they were saying to jules come out
of the water come out of the water
and she's saying you know
what was going on. You know.
Anyway so jill stood up
to sort of get a close on
and they just looked at the figure you
know until then they were just looking at
these don't come on girlie you know.
Get your clothes and you see the
uk pregnant and she said you.
How do you think watermelon will
be really cheeky to them you know
but it was just seemed the most ludicrous
thing which was of course i mean
apparently the fisherman had
told the guy at the caravan park
and the guy at the caravan park hated
hippies so he rang the police thinking this
is a good. You know this is a good one.
And so they had to walk
like i know kilometre
or something over this
track to get to us anyway.
So anyway by this time jules's
realised that something's going on.
So i called and said come
and get you close on.
So we did you know sort of a fashion
and we had to follow them one walked in
front and walked behind and off we went
and. Trying to communicate with
each other because we didn't want.
I didn't want to knowledge
that we had this bloody car because
none of us had that's right
and there's a little bit of something or
other in the glove box plus all our names.
You know letters
and you know just all our stuff our
whole life was in bloody leading pussy.
So i wasn't drunk.
A car you know so as we went past we just
go over my little wave and we went on
and so they put us in the
police can't talk association
and they actually had to ring up to find
out what to charge us with so they went
for the criminal charge which was offensive
behaviour and will fingerprinted
and searched and they had to
search our belongings and.
I had a certain belonging that
really they didn't like looking at
and i told them i wouldn't they had no
woman there so you know one of the police
and had to go the toilet.
I mean it was just crazy.
They could have just said you know you
know we're not going to answer this call.
But they obviously wanted to make
a stand and it was something
that people were being offended by at
that point in time with the people with
that close on no matter how far away.
You went from everybody. It was just.
An issue. So we got locked up but.
We told them that jill would be very
upset if she was locked in a cell
and might bring on her birth.
So i didn't even dare and they locked
us up to date in the exercise yard.
So when glazier singing
not gone like forms of.
Honey you know it was that was
really you know learn that song
and they brought us some fish and
chips because we were vegetarians
and wholemeal bread and huge mustard.
And by then we rang gray and.
You clarice foundation by
water so they let us out.
And meanwhile i can't still around the
beach and still didn't have a baby.
Thank god.
That we had to go to court
you know that whole thing
and the whole of nimbin turned up at the
court which of course didn't do any good
for us. I mean that has made it much
worse and the other thing was that.
That morning we had to get to
court so we had to still i think.
We stole his car and left a note
on the footpath under a rock sign.
But we just had to take your car
so when we got back into his car.
The police pulled us up and so this
guy was so i mean that was ok.
Of course as soon as we found
him and said look i think
that we had to go to court and it
was like that. You know. Just.
It was a funny time. Very interesting.
He said oh yes we were guilty
but oh yes.
Yes we were all fined $50 or 10 days
and nobody was going to do 10 days.
So we were promised we would
give them 50 dollars. A.
Those of.